actually
[Laughter]
and I just saw the move aruke three I
showed her because hopefully she didn't
see it during the game I didn't see of
course I would play something
but even after he played yes level
um I was I was looking at all kind of
stalemates and here like in this moment
and I saw this ideas like
laughs
oh well congratulations
[Laughter]
yes but I think uh psychologically she
has resigned the game oh my God it's
just unbelievable so it's like how much
do you say to do to win the game yeah I
had so much luck in this game so like
who oh my God so what it was the another
critical point
game
actually I didn't know what if she would
play if she would play a Roka ae1 I
didn't know exactly what to do when she
played instead of move from uh yeah
instead of D6 I wasn't sure if she would
but I didn't know what to do after Rook
ae1 so I was calculating lines and I
didn't decide what to do here so so I
think it's a knight G4 and IG folk win
B7 Rook 88 yes I was thinking this but
yes I did this position computer
evaluate just slightly better for white
I thought Oh I thought it was just bad
for me how can defend how can defend
Pawn
maybe it was fine for me how did you
feel during the game did you feel
confident
oh no I cannot say just time I'm just
just shocked with this rookie stream of
for such things here
well no no in this situation didn't like
my position anymore and then when did
the tables turn because I think that
Bella over pushed it here no no I think
I think here uh if she would win a five
I think was better much better and this
this I'm not sure if I would do it more
maybe I could just play without a pawn
because I think a queen and game is bad
for Me Maybe I'm Wrong and I think I was
thinking here maybe not to take porn but
play Something Something Different yeah
just to keep heavy pieces on the board
because I think wins and game and stuff
for me yeah we were trying to analyze
this yeah I think it's I didn't like it
I didn't like I was thinking maybe yes I
know I take a pawn but I think it's
white has very good chances to win this
one okay so you wanted to keep the yes
yes plain peace plain upon down but
then I think another critical moment was
when Bella played uh A4 so no I think
that's a draw no no okay after after
no after A4 it's fine it's still fine I
think no no I think the computer
evaluation
so she needed to start because
she wanted to play comfortably yes so
this so probably she thought that any
move draws here so after before you made
the very strong move King yeah it's like
such an uptrap yeah exactly so and
computer thinks that you were much
better here and yeah already yes so then
we can come back to this beautiful
oh my God this is
nightmare why did you do your choice to
me
I think well nowadays the information
you know spread it so quickly so you
would discover it poor Bella also or
your poor husband
I need to call him right away because
you have delay before you saw this and
does he help you with your preparations
during this event yeah of course yeah
this line here he didn't help me but
yeah like in general he's always helping
me with her parents and so I I I hope
that maybe
[Laughter]
so tell me what what should your I do
after such a game or maybe some piece of
advice some piece of advice maybe maybe
a glass of French wine no I think it's a
better like swimming pool
Elizabeth just told us that she's
swimming every morning so maybe
yesterday
no but maybe after the game of course I
saw this idea this is not something new
for me I saw these ideas so yes before
and like I like studies I like solving
puzzles but this was just completely
like after five hours playing
preparation with such a tense game we're
all like this game shows we have to play
until the very end even if it looks like
yes to keep your concentration yes yes
keep concentration and uh like if I will
have a very bad position I will probably
never resign
okay it's a very important lesson for
all of us thank you Anna congratulations
on your videos okay
we really liked your time management
today
they liked your time management today
because they they told us uh horrific
stories about
[Laughter]
they were worried all the time no I
think like literally but I wasn't like
much in temporary before
so yes uh congratulations once again and
well for you
I think we should remove this position
the only thing I can add Anna is thank
you for your inspiring Victory
very well done very well done as we